y'all are my homies so it's like y'all
could get anything you know what i mean
but
really like on the outside and you know
uh
just shock value and all of that stuff
click bait it's
it's a dark real scary place and i'll
take that [ __ ] personally
like like for real for real if somebody
uses me
for for a headline yeah that's not cool
like that's not what we're in it for
so even to try to set people up like
that and make things out of we
i've never been in it for that well i
feel like you also don't do a lot of
like you do interviews but you're not
like you don't do like a lot of sit-down
[ __ ] like yeah
you know what i mean like i feel like i
was just thinking about it earlier today
i don't i don't do a lot of that but
well i do but it doesn't go crazy
because nobody
[ __ ] with me like nobody and i feel
like you're very good
at when someone tries to hit you with
one of those gotcha joints right you
just shut that [ __ ] down
yeah for sure i mean it's it's
definitely
a mutual respect where i'm like okay you
you got to do what you got to do you got
to try to get these questions off
but i'm not going to break my character
or you know my integrity
for your headlines you dig what i'm
saying we're going to keep it light
we're going to keep it cool and if
that's not
interesting then you don't even want wiz
you know what i'm saying but i'm not
coming here for no drama
or no [ __ ] and i think people really
understand that and they don't really
approach me with that they don't try to
bring that out
and yeah i feel very fortunate to have
that be a part of my career you did
yeah 100 man